ladies and gentlemen
winner Jodie Foster
hmm transformer translator painter three
of the hats the cinematographer wears
not to mention the most important one
baseball cap with the Sun Visor this
year's nominees range from the starkest
black-and-white film noir to the most
outrageous explosion of musical comedy
color they are window then bone n4i midi
Slavonia EADS yak for Black Hawk Down
Andrew Lesley for the Lord of the Rings
the Fellowship of the Ring Roger Deakins
for the man who wasn't there Donald M
MacAlpine from Moulin Rouge and the
Oscar goes to Andrew Lesley for the Lord
of the Rings succession
unless knees first Academy Award
ironically he took a few days to say yes
to Lord of the Rings project because he
had long believed but the true cinematic
vision of the work could never be made
um right
it's the concierge is card from the Roma
Taj
I'd like to thank the Academy a new line
I'd like to thank Marco deskey and Carla
Frye Peter Jackson who was a sensational
person to work with Fran Walsh and Barry
Osborne for giving me the opportunity to
work on an amazing project at the
privilege of working with a really two
sensational cast and terrific crews
predominantly New Zealand I want to send
my love to my partner Bronwyn and my
sons Jack and Sam who were probably
still at school in Sydney I just want to
say Australia and New Zealand
terrific places to grow up and and great
to work it and great to live in and last
of all I want to dedicate this to the
late Brian band's Grove who was the
chief lighting technician on Lord of the
Rings on the trilogy and Brian this is
for you thank you
Helen Hunt Cameron Diaz samuel l.jackson
join us when the oscars returned live
from Hollywood's new Kodak Theatre
you